[Music]
you may think you know everything about
Lola from the loud house but there is
more to her than meets the eye
stay tuned to find out what big secret
Lola is hiding new around here don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up and subscribe to the things for more
great videos like this now on to ten
things about Lola from the loud house
you never noticed she's a mastermind
after you have seen a couple of episodes
with Lola you'll notice that she is not
one to play with do not let her cute
exterior fool you she can sweet-talk her
way out of anything honestly it is just
best to stay on her good side
a lot of people would write off the
six-year-old as evil like you've got to
admit it takes brains to have everything
work in your favor the way it always
does for Lola she is the self-proclaimed
star of the show who has to have it her
way and in a house with ten other
siblings that is definitely not an easy
feat this pageant queen is definitely
conniving and has earned the title of
troublemaker she's hard working be
honest how many six-year-olds do you
know that are as serious about their
craft as Lola loud Lola will sometimes
entertain the activities of her siblings
but we all know what is on top of her
priority list winning her dress her
tiara and pearls are all very
fashionable and clearly show that she
believes in dressing the part of a
princess this girl eats sleeps and
briefs pageantry have you ever seen the
little pageant girls forced to walk
across the stage and participate in
pageants Lola will and has eaten them
alive she does not play when it comes to
her crown which is probably why it never
comes off some may see it as vanity but
the young star sees what she wants and
goes after it
she loves to fight this characteristic
can probably be said for any of the loud
siblings but you would not expect Queen
Lola's v12 scuffle to be honest it is
not really a part of the pageantry brand
however Lola never turns down a fight
whether she and her twin are rumbling
down the steps or she's enjoying
disagreeing with Lincoln there is not a
chance that she is backing down from a
scuffle not only will she step to you in
her lipstick in heels she gives all her
siblings a run for their money
not something you would expect from a
character that fancies tea parties every
other episode but pageants do prefer a
multi-faceted queen
they she loves her twin / siblings
people love to view Lola as the mean
Queen always causing turmoil in the loud
house for the most part that isn't wrong
she will manipulate anyone in her path
however this is not always her demeanor
towards certain people especially her
twin those two girls truly share a bond
while being total opposites and having
nothing in common she even gave her twin
Lana her crown once which was a huge
love signal to her twin sister Lana and
Lola are inseparable when they are
devising plans and then other times are
each other's throats but isn't that
common with siblings she gives praise
where it's due as the most selfish loud
house family member it's hard to fathom
Lola being understanding or even
impressed by anything not involving
herself but it actually happens slowly
always has to be number one and is
number one in her mind but she is quick
to let you know when she is impressed I
don't like what you did he did win and I
respect a winner
Queen Lola actually said these words and
proceeded to let Lana wear her crown
proclaiming she deserved it after
pretending to be Lola a queen that can
turn the pageant monster off and give
praise when it's earned is totally
commendable she can be vulnerable do you
remember the reading challenge episode
where we found out Lola could not read
we have never seen the Queen more
vulnerable and open she definitely has a
soft side even though we don't see it
very often in the episode she opens up
to Lincoln when she realizes that she
cannot win the challenge since she
cannot read it's rare to see her put
someone else before herself but in this
episode Lola considers all 11 of her
siblings feelings when she wanted to
drop out of the competition in true loud
house tradition no one was left behind
and everyone pitched in to help her she
is hilarious Lola loves dramatics are a
highlight of the show once you look past
her constantly trying to rule every
situation and person you will find that
Lola is pretty funny
a six year old constantly referencing
her beauty sleep a Lincoln I need my
beauty rest
and what she will not tolerate will
never not be hilarious the girl has
standards and her diva attitude and
witty comebacks are only overshadowed by
the idea of her being a pageant obsessed
little girl who enjoys wrecking havoc
on the household if you haven't seen the
show you will definitely find her funny
when you hear her high-pitched screams
that she does so often either way if the
show were about anyone other than
Lincoln it would be a Lola comedy
special every week she likes a challenge
it may be the pageant girl in her but
Lola never backs down from a challenge
no matter how repulsed she is by
whatever her twin or anyone else do not
matter suggests she's always there to
experience new things this could also be
because she's only six and does not want
to miss out on anything
most people definitely think of Lana as
the adventurous twin but wherever Lana
is Lola is not far behind
even if she's complaining the whole time
this could be Lola's way of practicing
doing whatever it takes to be on top she
never gives up she can be selfless Lola
is not miss Bossypants all the time
there are moments where she puts her
siblings needs before hers while these
moments are few and far between there
episodes when Lola is genuinely
compassionate towards her siblings and
lends a helping hand to where it's
needed the episode where Lola helped her
siblings pass a test that she felt was a
moment where she was in rare form
exemplifying concern and compassion
don't get us wrong Lola will always be
all about Lola but she knows how to put
herself second when it matters and it
always matters when her siblings are in
trouble she wants to fit in if you were
to randomly pick up on a series you
would not guess that Lola is the
outsider but she is sometimes and she
hates it this could be the reason that
she is so evil to everyone and enjoys
controlling everything and one episode
Lola finally admits why she is conniving
towards her siblings all the time
eavesdropping on all their secrets and
everything it was the only way she says
this is not the Lola that is portrayed
often we almost never see her being
sensitive and open in this episode she
makes it clear that her siblings
approval means a lot to her and she does
not like feeling left out of course her
siblings welcome her back with open arms
because who can resist the queen of
mischief so that's it for 10 things
about Lola from the loud house you never
noticed were you surprised by any of the
things on this list let us know in the
comments
[Music]